so this one hopefully by the time you've
gone through the previous ones you like
are actually in some ways this is not so
bad number one did you notice I know
Michonne called it out but maybe didn't
hear this graph or both of the graphs
rather that we're multiplying together
they are really nice-looking
they have symmetry did you notice that
what kind of symmetry do both of the
parabolas have they both have it along
the y-axis we have a name for this
starts with an E it's even symmetry
right so you like all if it's even
symmetry for both of them you take two
symmetrical objects you're putting
together guess what
you'll get another symmetrical object
does that make sense to everything you
do on one side ends up mirroring over to
the other you like cool half the work
right how much about what am i shaded do
you notice want to shade it don't below
why is that as you go from left to right
right one of the graphs is always
positive and then the other graph will
be negative positive negative positive
negative positive negative irrespective
of size so long as you multiply a
positive number by a negative one you
always get a negative result okay and
then you can like oh it's just gonna
wiggle around a whole lot right so I'm
going to try and do my best to join the
dots I'm gonna get something like that
and then it's gonna go down like that
oops that's gone let me try that again
there we go
by the way a quick thing that I wanted
to point out again it's just a point of
I'm just going to point it out as an
interesting thing and we'll figure
explanations later this is a cubic Part
B is a cubic remember that how many
stationary points does I have one two
two one two
this guy here it's a parabola right how
many stationary points is I have one
this guy here is a quartic how many
stationary places I have that's
interesting something which has oh wait
one last one well sure I can't slide
this thing uh-huh
straight line straight line here how
many stationary points that have
no stationary points think about this
right this is X to the power of 1 it has
no stationary points this is X to the
power of 2 it has one stationary point X
to the power of three has two stationary
points and then lastly X to power four
has three or it can have three anyway
that's interesting isn't it just Park
that thought for now okay so two things
bless you I realized that I've never
actually written on the board or said
explicitly like we we we know what it
looks like when you are when
algebraically when you're doing the
reciprocal that's what the reciprocal
looks like I've never actually written
what does it what are we doing right
this is what we are doing if you get
this is by the way that's the I did my
best to try and I think that's I think
I've got the equations right if you've
got two functions what we're actually
calculating is or graphing rather what
is one function multiplied by the org I
want f of X multiplied by G of X okay
now I just want to show this example
because I've been having a look at what
you guys have done and some of them the
shapes good are the ones it's like you
need more points to get more accuracy
because when you put these together
would you please compare this I'll just
make it black so it stands out a little
more would you compare this to what
you've got now have a look at your shape
have a look at this shape
do you notice it's smooth all the way
through there are some Wiggles but
they're the kinds of things you expect
at fairly significant points right you
can see it should be I should be able to
draw one smooth line away through a lot
of you was kind of like it sort of zig
zags around what that comes down to is
okay do you have enough points to know
where this is going and are the points
you're putting on are they accurate
right so the more accurate you'll be the
the better you can I know for some of
these it's quite hard to read what's
going on we promise if we give you a
graph in a test but it will be big
enough that you can actually see where
every single value is and the actual
upshot is the less accurate the graph
they hand you is the less accuracy
you're expected to if there's like a
grid like a super ultrafine grid on this
like so okay there's no excuses because
you know where every single values you
can read it off there right so we will
expect you to also be precise does that
sense